je veux d'abord me réjouir du succès de
la primaire de la droite et du centre
puisque dimanche dernier plus de quatre
millions d'entre vous vous à déplacer
pour aller voter c'est un signe de bonne
santé de notre démocratie
maintenant nous allons vers le deuxième
tour et s'il ya un deuxième tour c'est
qu'il ya débat un débat pour que vous
puissiez mieux connaître nos projets
afin de vous décider en toute
connaissance de cause
je voudrais vous dire dans quel état
d'esprit j'aborde ce débat françois nous
ne connaissons depuis bien longtemps
nous sommes entrés en politique presque
en même temps nous avons toujours
appartenu à la même famille politique
avait été mon ministre et j'étais le
tien et puis c'est que j'ai toujours eu
pour toi de l'amitié et de l'estiment et
je n'ai pas changé d'avis c'est à dire
il ya des règles dans un débat dans un
débat on peut se poser des questions
c'est ce que j'ai fait quand tes
positions ou thé proposition ne
paraissait pas tout à fait claires et
j'étais un peu surpris de la virulence
de ta réponse nous allons continuer à
débattre et nous aurons des convergences
seront aussi des divergences je n'ai pas
l'intention de les éluder parce que des
français qui nous regardons droit à la
clarté et la précision mes objectifs
sont clairs et précis réarmer d'abord
l'état pour qu'il protège efficacement
les français contre le terrorisme contre
l'islamisme radical contre toutes les
menaces qui pèsent sur nous aujourd'hui
libérer l'énergie des entreprises du
poids excessif des charges et des
contraintes qui les empêche de créer des
emplois modernisée en profondeur notre
éducation nationale pour qu'elle donne à
chacun de nos enfants les mêmes chances
de réussir sa vie et puis préparer
l'avenir de nos jeunes aussi en étant
ouvert à une autre façon de vivre pour
mieux préserver la planète et notre
santé et puis en maîtrisant en
contrôlant les progrès immenses que va
nous apporter la numérisation du monde
pour atteindre ses objectifs je suis
décidé à faire des réformes profondes
sérieuse crédible mais sans brutalité
parce que je veux que les français
comprennent que ces réformes leur
apporteront au mieux un progrès dans la
vie quotidienne voilà de quoi nous
allons débattre je l'espère